wird der rote überriesen peter koits in
dieser riesenstern jetzt explodieren er
beherrscht seit wochen die
astronomischen news einige forschende
behauptet nun eine supernova ist es
nicht aber und jetzt kommt s es gab
tatsächlich eine explosion dort krieg
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen und meint ein experte heute
ist team von astro comics tv was ist
eigentlich mit betreuter los der
riesenstern fällt in den letzten wochen
durch extremst widersprüchliches
verhalten auf sicherlich habt ihr schon
gehört dass einige astronomen davon
ausgingen oder ausgehen dass er bald in
einer supernova explodieren wird und das
liegt daran dass er sich extremst
verdunkelt hat ursprünglich war
wettergott hellste stern am nachthimmel
der schulter stern von orion ist einer
der prägnantesten sterne überhaupt und
sichern ich habe ihn auch schon mal am
nachthimmel bewundert vor einigen wochen
begann er dann allerdings sich zu
verdunkeln und letztlich war er nicht
mehr details der stern am nachthimmel
sondern nur noch der 21 hältst und das
war der grund warum viele astronomen
davon ausgingen dass er explodieren wird
da sie diese verdunkelung als eine art
zusammenziehen vor der explosion gesehen
haben ja wir haben dann vergeblich
darauf gewartet dass er explodiert ist
immer noch da und jetzt mehren sich die
stimmen die sagen es kommt gar nicht zu
einer supernova aber immer der reihe
nach was ist überhaupt eine supernova
genau ihr könnt euch vorstellen in jedem
stern findet eine art fusionsprozess
statt das heißt meistens wird
wasserstoff zu helium fusionieren und
dadurch entsteht energie und hitze
irgendwann allerdings ist der komplette
wasserstoff aufgebraucht es gibt auch
helium und der stern fängt an zu sterben
während er in seinem todeskampf dann
immer schwerere elemente fusioniert im
ersten schritt helium kohlenstoff blähte
sich zu einem roten riesen auf stößt
dann explosionsartig seine hülle ab und
das nennt man supernovas kann heftiger
werden oder heller als eine gesamte
galaxie ein explodierender stern und
heller als hunderte milliarden in der
milchstraße beteigeuze ist schon ein
roter
diese also dass er nicht mehr allzu
lange hat das steht fest nur der
streitpunkt ist eben wie lange hat er
dann auch und jetzt sagen eben viele
astronomen diese verdunkelung das war
wahrscheinlich teil eines normalen
sternen zyklus in dem wettergott mehr
material fusionieren und dadurch mal
heller wird dann wieder weniger und
dunkler wird denn das wetter so
helligkeits zyklen hat das hat man den
vergangenheit tatsächlich schon länger
beobachtet und das war jetzt vielleicht
nur ein sehr heftiger ausschlag
ein team von astronomen um den forscher
miguel montage wollte der sache mal auf
den grund gehen und hat mit dem
sogenannten very large telescope das
gehört der europäischen weltraumbehörde
und steht aber in chile
damit wollten die der sache auf den
grund gehen und haben fotos vom
wettergott zugemacht
die bilder die dabei herausgekommen sind
zeigen was wir schon vermutet haben
nämlich das better golze sehr viel
dunkler geworden ist dennoch geht der
leitende forscher miguel montage nicht
davon aus dass es sich um eine supernova
handelt er sagt dazu die beiden
szenarien an denen wir arbeiten bestehen
in einer abkühlung der oberfläche
aufgrund einer außergewöhnlichen stern
aktivität oder eines staub aus wurst in
unsere richtung
das heißt entweder es handelt sich eben
nur um eine zyklische verdunkelung die
wieder abnimmt oder zwischen unserem
bett gehen könnte sich eine
interstellare staubwolke befinden
überall im weltraum schwören gigantische
staubwolken rum in dem teilweise auch
neue sterne geboren werden und die
könnten unseren blick auf wetterkreuz
vernebeln in dem fall hätten wir im
wahrsten sinne des wortes einfach nur
etwas staub auf der linse und genau das
ist passiert beteigeuze wurde wieder
heller
aber warum verdunkelte er sich dann
forschende der universität washington
und eslohe observatoriums haben es
herausgefunden es gab tatsächlich eine
explosion der rote überriesen hat eine
riesige staubwolke quasi aus genießt und
die hat ihn verdunkelt und das ist
nichts ungewöhnliches für solche sterne
dazu die astronomen evelyn levesque wir
beobachten das häufig bei roten
überriesen es ist ein normaler teil
ihres lebenszyklus sie werfen
gelegentlich material von ihrer
oberfläche ab das als staub
stern herum kondensiert während dieser
sich abkühlt und auflöst absorbieren die
staubkörner einen teil des lichts das zu
uns strahlt und blockieren so die sicht
vielen dank für die zusammenarbeit auf
seinem kanal geht es weiter mit
spektakuläre supernova explodieren teil
kreuze anklicken und anschauen um noch
mehr infos zum supernova szenario zu
bekommen dass er immer noch möglich ist
und astro comics tv abonnieren dem ziel
ist es in den nächsten tagen die 20.000
abos mit seinem channel zu knacken also
schaffen wir das heute ihr habt es mit
einem klick hier in der hand bis dann
bleib dran